you either die an anime fan or you live
long enough to see yourself become a
margarita Sun Tzu God of War Ragnarok
maybe you've only started watching anime
maybe even watching it for years maybe
you don't even watch anime anymore but
you still watch these videos what the
hell are you still doing here eventually
we all reached that point where there
you are watching the anime talking about
how much you're enjoying that anime and
then there'll be that one [__]
friend who will rise up and go why are
you watching the anime just read the
Manga bro it's so much better and maybe
out of pure spite you go ahead and read
it just so for once in your life you can
shut that guy up but when you do you
realize [__]
I'm friends with a [__] the manga
was better is a phrase that's become
synonymous Community to the point where
it's inescapable but how much weight
does it actually hold what makes a good
adaptation what makes a bad adaptation
is the manga actually better is your
friend really a [__]
yes we know who isn't today's sponsor
bespoke post gentlemen and ladies do you
like cool stuff of course you do who
doesn't like cool stuff well bespoke
post has got you covered bespoke post is
a membership club for top shelf goods
and under the radar Brands where you'll
receive a box of awesome Goods every
single month it's completely free to
sign up and you'll have flexibility to
cancel anytime you want I am so glad to
be working with bespoke posts again
because since they last sent me some
stuff I've genuinely still use it this
is their handy bag I got from their week
in the Box last time and as you can see
since I've been traveling so much this
year I have gotten a lot of use out of
this it's genuinely been so perfect
every time I go for a short weekend trip
or when I just need to throw some
equipment in when I'm going to a shoot
each one of these boxes of awesome
contain around 70 worth of items but
costs you a fraction of that value every
month you'll be introduced to cool new
products ranging from outdoor gear
barware home and kitchen goods clothing
and so much more 90 of the products come
from small Brands many of which are
based in the US all tailored to your
personal taste after filling out your
personal preferences and don't worry if
you don't like everything they choose
for you because each month you can
preview all the items you're gonna get
so you can choose to keep it swap it for
another box or just veto the month
entirely you'll only pay for what you
want and you'll never get products that
aren't useful to you this month I'm
going to be receiving their points cask
and roast box to try out of all of these
I think I'm most excited to try out the
White Oak mini Barrow and bottling kit
from the cast box to really level up my
newfound appreciation I've gotten for
Japanese whiskey since I've been moving
here so what are you waiting for to get
20 off your first box of awesome you can
click the link in the description use
code giga20 at the checkout or just go
to bespoke.com Gig up 20. thank you
again to bespoke post for sponsoring me
today back to the video the topic of
Manga and Anime adaptations is a long
and nuanced discussion that's been had
so many times in our community that I
don't even know where I can even begin
like Godwin's law every conversation you
have about manga adaptations will
eventually lead you one step closer to
mentioning berserk you have arguably the
greatest manga at your fingertips and
one of the greatest stories ever told so
surely if you just stick to the source
material no matter how it looks can an
adaptation that stays completely
faithful to the story and characters
still be bad the Black Swordsman you yes
but Sonic 2016 is The Benchmark of
everything that could go wrong in an
adaptation it's the boogeyman other
mangas tell each other when they're
sitting around at the campfire if you're
a bad boy the berserk monster is going
to come visit your Animation Studio no
Daddy please I've been a good boy please
give me a good adaptation yeah well tell
that to promise Neverland over there but
adaptations don't really need to be as
bad in this order of magnitude for the
manga to be better in fact berserk has
not had one not two but three chances to
get it right with all of them having
their own shortcomings we see with a lot
of other adaptations the movies had
updated animations some beautiful scenes
but sacrificed precious time building up
its cast of characters so many anime
have had the Dilemma of okay we only
have a certain amount of run time so do
we focus on those big climatic moments
or a quiet scene with the characters
[__] it get rid of all those choir Parts
not realizing that it's those nuanced
character scenes that make those big
moments hit so hard in the first place
ironically the best adaptation berserk
got was its first one which is only
really held back by a [__] you
Cliffhanger ending an animation that can
rival PowerPoint presentation it's still
a really good anime because well it's
[__] bizarre but here's the real
question can I definitively say that
even though this is a good anime it does
enough to Warrant a watch over just
solely reading the Masterpiece of the
manga well yes because it gave us some
of the best dub outtakes of all time all
right who's gonna jerk me off
sometimes I ask myself if an anime
follows a manga one to one and all it
does is add music color and voice acting
is that enough to call it a good
adaptation and for me that answer is no
if I watch the first episode and I see
that all you're doing is adding a
generic soundtrack and mediocre
animation [__] it I'm just gonna go read
the Manga and say I'll watch the anime
don't lie to me I know you've done the
same look man I'm a grown ass adult now
with grown ass responsibilities and we
know reading manga is basically watching
anime except you can do it way faster to
me an anime really needs to do something
above average to Warren to watch because
so many come in with the philosophy of
being a glorified advert for the source
material anyway that's why seasonal
anime have low-key become a manga
recommendation platform for me for those
shows that I find catch my interest but
just have completely bogged standard
production values if you're wondering
how I go through so much isakai that's
the secret and on top of that before an
adaptation can even be good there are so
many things it has to avoid to be bad
back in the day long-running anime had
this obsession with staying on air for
as long as possible but every franchise
would run into the same problem of
catching up to the current manga it was
based on their solution ah let's just
make them do a bunch of stupid [__]
back when I first watched Naruto even my
dumbass 12 year old brain registered
something was off when I was like why
did Naruto go from chasing Sasuke to
becoming a giant robot there's no one
here have any urgency about what just
happened and it was then that I
discovered the concept of Filler
episodes thankfully modern day anime has
realized now that basically everyone
skipped Filler episodes anyway but where
it gets really messy is when the filler
starts getting integrated into normal
episodes and I hate to do this to one of
my favorite franchises of all time but
that's the reason I stopped watching One
Piece the one piece anime is something I
hold dear to my heart but after a
certain point the anime just became
unfucking watchable for me I'd noticed
several episodes in a row would have a
five minute recap of stuff I literally
just saw they'd keep cutting to
characters nobody gave a [__] about to
do a scene that doesn't [__] matter
pacing was murdered by characters
constantly pausing and having Extended
Stay Barrel so absolutely nothing was
achieved except padding out the run time
this is when filler ceases to be just
the minor inconvenience you can skip to
something that actively hurts the
viewing experience just so you can
stretch out the material you have as far
as possible and so I started reading the
manga and never looked back since
margaritas have this obsession with
getting a perfectly faithful adaptation
and it's easy to understand why we've
seen promised Neverland season 2 we've
seen Tokyo Ghoul root a we've seen what
happens when an anime looks at a manga
and goes no I'm actually gonna do my own
thing now bye bye [__] you anime
original endings shows that completely
rush through the source material the
list goes on and because of this it
feels like there's a pressure to stick
as closely to the manga as possible but
is being 100 faithful always the best
way to go the boys is a great example of
this it took a violent edgy for Edge
sake comic and reworked it to be a
modern satire of superheroes and
commercialization making a far more
interesting product than it ever was
that was diabolical
things Keon transformed a four coma
manga into a coherent ongoing storyline
with a bit of music sprinkled in that
became one of the most beloved Slice of
Life anime to ever come out Devilman
crybaby did well have you seen the
original devil man at all being faithful
while proving to be a stable route to
success can sometimes be a shackle the
anime is just trying to take every panel
every scene and putting them on the
screen because what I think we don't see
enough is what it means to adapt to
anime itself manga has a lot of
strengths as a medium you turn the page
of a ginger Ito horror manga and it's
effectively a jump scare you're greeted
with this detailed horrific imagery that
will haunt your nightmares gruesome
drawings that'll seep into your
unconscious never to leave your memories
again and in the anime it's like
what if Squidward have a baby with
Megamind transforming a manga to anime
doesn't mean just adding movement you
need to know what works for anime and
vice versa you know it's easy to show
you a panel of mob psycho 100 and a
scene from the anime and be like hmm I
wonder what's the best way to experience
this story but I think it goes deeper
than just animation equals good because
what I think is more important is
capturing the soul of the original or
translating it to what works best for
film and to make my point we need to
talk about something entirely different
line novels you can almost always tell
within five minutes when a show is
adapting from a light novel as opposed
to a manga characters aren't afraid to
go on overly indulgent internal
monologues there will be long scenes of
nothing but just dialogue between two or
more characters with almost nothing
visually interesting going on character
a is talking okay cut to character a
standing still and talking character B
starts talking okay Cuts character B A
is talking again okay cut back to a then
B again then a
it all feels so rigid like an AI program
looked at the script and went okay plot
understood here are your storyboards and
only in the rarest moments does it feel
like any thought was put into the visual
aspects beyond the dramatic scenes and
action moments katamang adaptations boom
instantly dialogue is used more
sparingly you normally get a sense
there's a bigger emphasis on visual
storytelling which makes sense because
did you know
manga has visuals of course there are
exceptions for on a whole anime based on
manga often feel very different anime
based on light novels because the source
material is always written or drawn with
their original medium in mind but
shouldn't the anime take this into
account you look at a dynamic shot like
this and you immediately feel alright
now this is an anime original production
not bound to any manga but when you want
anime could do things that are suited
only for anime like one of the big
things where manga can falter it's in
the action I'm sure we've all read that
one manga where there's that big epic
fight happening punches are being thrown
swords are swinging [__] is hitting the
metaphorical fan and you're like
I can't tell what's going on subtle
movements in intense action scenes can
easily get lost on a still page so
Morgan needs to compensate by portraying
big clearly defined actions so the
reader doesn't lose track of what's
going on or just have a bloody monologue
explain it take a look at this
live-action choreographed fight scene
this one's a favorite of mine you have
two guys fighting the protagonist and
the big boss and the big boss is always
all invade in Split seconds no
explanation you can see what's going on
now if this was a manga this fly would
be like okay well he's gonna do is
throwing mid kick to my left what I'm
gonna do is catch his kicked and elbow
his leg so he can't kick anymore and the
other guy would be like haha fool I'll
just bend my leg at the last second
block his elbow and nullifying his
attack oh no he bought my elbow well in
that case what I do next is the great
thing about anime is that these rules do
not apply so why is it that almost every
adaptation pretends that it doesn't more
often than not anime fights of a manga
have the pacing of the manga fight the
framing looks exactly the same actions
get explained even if we can clearly
convey it through movement now unless
you're embracing the chaos like Jojo or
Bucky you shouldn't always need to do
this part of the reason I love the
Hanami pipe from Jiu Jitsu Kaizen is
that it strikes that perfect balance of
explaining Toto's power but still
showing the effect it has on the
opponent but that doesn't even need to
be any complex action going on you
fightable looked at Demon Slayer and
went okay this fight isn't too
complicated so how much can we push the
climax of this one heart how much can we
raise the bar of pipe and excitement to
build towards this one moment and that
resulted in a scene with one of the
highest visual spectacles anime has seen
this was one of the moments that defined
this year of anime and this incredible
this out of the world scene was five
[__] panels in the manga I mean look
at this there was a whole panel
explaining uzui's sound power and the
word no no no no we don't need this
[__] this will just mess up with the
pacing we can show this visually I then
proceeded to turn this
into
[__] might as well have just
turned water into wine but this isn't
limited to action scenes either one of
my favorite scenes from Naruto comes
from a moment with Shikamaru spoilers
for Naruto Shippuden if you still care
about that Shikamaru has just lost his
team leader and they're all in the
process of mourning randomly his father
invites him to play a game of shogi
which isn't too unusual for the two of
them and in two minutes of one single
unbroken shot his father slowly lectures
him during the game and in that moment
his father has given him permission to
let out all the pent-up feelings he's
been holding on inside
is amazing it's a master class of
cinematography and visual storytelling
and it is not in the manga at all yeah
by the technical definition this is
actually filler it's [__] like this like
anime a scene like this would have never
worked as well in manga form but with a
different approach you can take what a
manga tried to convey and translate into
something only anime can do berserk
Vagabond Uzumaki goodbye Arie these
masterpieces of manga work so well
because they are manga and fully utilize
their medium to The Highest Potential
you can turn to some of these panels and
it feels like a painting you can pause
the page analyze every little detail
every single scratch of the pen the
artist etched into this page you can
take that moment to just take it all in
and Marvel in the moment for as long as
you need and in the anime it's like oh
hey that's a pretty background and it's
gone this is just an inherent difference
in the medium and the only chance an
anime will ever get to adapting these
works well is if it can actually play to
the strengths of its own medium rather
than trying to emulate the strengths of
another which is so goddamn rare is the
manga better honestly yes
most of the time so many more things can
go wrong before they go right you need
to have the right production the right
resources the right time to make a good
adaptation and even then if it doesn't
do enough to go above and beyond a lot
of us are probably gonna end up picking
up the manga anyway but the reason I'll
never stop being an Anime Watcher
completely is because when an adaptation
does get it right anime can elevator
manga to Heights it could never reach by
itself when you get a truly special
adaptation that you get to experience
for the first time on screen it is a
magical experience I will never stop
chasing no matter how many mediocre
adaptations I need to sit through
and the guy's still a [__]
[Music]
flabberwocky I veto Jeff lovados
misaka12315 Hayne Patrick Tony Stark
waltergeist VT and everyone else on my
patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible and guys it is that time of the
year again we are coming up to the end
of the year and yes I am currently
catching up to all the anime I missed
that has aired in the past year and
gotta say I'm looking forward to it
because there's a lot of shows that I'm
looking forward to watching all the way
through so yes I am working on my best
of 2022 anime of the year so keep a look
out for that probably within the New
Year I'll probably have another video
out before then anyway anyway though
that's it from me today hope you're
getting your Christmas shopping done
right now I've been gig up and I'll see
you all next time